hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Next Generation dendritic
cell-based vaccines
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by milteni biotech to learn more visit
meltinibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Dr Christina Conforti andreoni Global
product manager and group leader
marketing Immunology from attendee
biotech and Dr Marius during team
coordinator and project leader in the
personalized immunotherapy team with
meltene biotech Christina and Maris you
may now begin your presentation
welcome to this webinar about next
Generation dendritic cell vaccines I am
Christina confortiandriani and together
with my colleague Mario storing I will
give you an overview on the past present
and future of the sea vaccination and an
insight into the military biotech
solution for bloody sea manufacturing
with the clinomax Prodigy platform
let's start with an overview on the
agenda I will first introduce the
concept of the sea-based cancer vaccine
with a short view on the history and
Status Quo of the Sea therapy followed
then by a deeper look at the New Concept
of blood disease based vaccines then
Marius will present our solution for
bloody C manufacturing with Clinic Max
Prodigy platform and how it serves the
needs of many generating cell scientists
who want to bring the basic Research
into clinical with a seamless
translation
finally you will have a chance to ask
some questions and to discuss together
with us some of the key points
we all know that vaccines are among the
most successful medical interventions in
the history of humankind having saved
millions of lives and the first vaccine
was developed by Edward yenna in the
1700s against smallpox by using material
from the cowpox virus from which by the
way comes the terms vaccines which in
Latin means cow
since the several since then several
advancements have been done to apply the
concept of vaccination to other
infectious diseases thanks also to the
work of pasture and other great
microbiologists in the 1800s and in the
1900s
however only in the second part of the
1900s in the Philadelphia Immunology
started to fully develop and the
mechanism behind vaccination the
so-called Dirty Little Secret of
vaccines and the natural immune response
became more and more clear
and an important Milestone was also for
example a discovery of dendritis cells
and they roll in the T Cell Activation
but also the senses of pathogen via till
are ligands and other receptors and the
concept of antigens
with the progress of Immunology a
researcher and and similar research in
the field it became more clear that
immune response can be manipulated in
several ways besides the standard
vaccination against infectious diseases
and a lot of research moved into the
direction of using the immune system to
induce response against cancer
in the 2000 the field of immuno oncology
and the immunotherapy exploded and we
could see several clinical trials
running to test different molecules and
different cellular drugs including the
therapeutic antibodies against
checkpoint inhibitor and also engineer T
Cell so-called car T which in some cases
will also approved a standard therapies
for some type of cancers
at the same time the classical
vaccination evolved in two direction on
one side to explore the use of dendritic
cells as cellular Vector for antigens
and on the other side with the
development of
um
rna-based vaccines which as you know
that we are actually very crucial for
the fight of the kovi 19 pandemic
and in the case of cancer vaccination
another important player was the concept
of using new antigen based vaccines and
indeed the Next Generation vaccine any
monotherapy in general are all projected
for the next Century on the idea that
standard medicine should become more and
more personalized and tailored on the
patient profiling
we have seen that the Next Generation
immunotherapy consists of several
different type of approaches but for
this webinar we would like to focus on
the the dirty cell based vaccination for
the cancer treatment
in this illustration you can see how it
works so the idea is that dendritis cell
can be generated from peripheral blood
of cancer patients and the first step is
to collect the blood and process it to
prepare a local Pharisee product
then demonocytes isolated from this
leopophoresis broader and culture with
specific cytokines that are the
interlocking four and the granulocyte
macrophages Colony stimulating Factor
usually after five or six days the
identity cells are fully differentiated
and can be done matured and loaded with
specific cancer antigen now one of the
expected key aspect of DC therapy is to
identify the correct antigens so there
are usually two possibilities antigens
can be isolated from the same patients
via collection of tumobiopsy and then
given to the seeing culture in the form
of tumorisate or tumor cells or tumor
protein but another way and it's a new
approach the future probably of um of
the sea therapies to sequence the tumor
that identify the so-called Neo antigens
or personalized mutated antigens of the
patients
which then can be synthesized as RNA or
peptide and given to the design culture
the other approach is instead to use of
the Shelf mRNA or peptides whose
sequence comes from the typical antigens
identifies as identified as recurrent in
several patients with a given tumor type
the so-called shared antigens
once ready the cellular product is
injected back into the patient where the
identity cells will induce an antigen
specific T-cell response which in turn
will attack the tumor cells
dendritic Cell Therapy has now been
experimented in several clinical trials
for more than 15 years and which are the
lessons learned so in general It is Well
tolerated and showed some positive
results however it is still not optimal
and needs further development to reach a
significant efficacy
it was observed indeed that the C
maturation is crucial
that the presence of functional antigen
specific T cells can really predict the
clinical outcome in the patients
and also the patients with lower tumor
burden have actually more antigen
specific T cells
also it was seen that presentation of
multiple epitopes on MHC class 1 and 2
is really beneficial and in general one
big problem still is the migration
the problem with troubleshooting of the
seed therapy is that the design of the
sea vaccine involves several variables
to take in consideration and even one
single wrong choice can cause a
sub-optimal performance of the vaccine
and even a complete failure of the
therapy
first of all
you need to choose which antigen you
want to use so whether it would be a off
the shelf to more Associated antigen or
a self antigen for example a new antigen
then we you need to decide on which form
this antigen should be given to the
identity cells as a synthetic peptide or
RNA or as an endogenous protein lysate
obtained from the tumor or inversionals
RNA for example
then the stimulus is really crucial as
mentioned DC needs to be mature
optimally this can be done with
cytokines cocktails with Tierra ligands
but there are also other ways for
example engineering DC so that they
acquire a specific function and
maturation status
the relative injection is also very
critical as mentioned the migration of
the sea is crucial and whether the DC
are injected in certain tissue or
another tissue might cause
um is above the migration uh usually it
can be done intraderma some try also
intravenous
in some cases intra-2 more because then
you will reach directly the place where
DDC can find the antigen and many
studies as we see later also focus on
the intra noodle because then the
disease is already in the lymph node and
can act directly to activate T cells
and a very important point is also where
is the sea vaccination applied in which
type of cancer and which stage of the
cancer whether it will be metastatics in
remission or even post surgery in
abduvant settings for example
which two more types should be the
target of this therapy the one with the
high mutation the one with the hot tumor
with a lot easily infiltration all my
work also in cold tumor and finally we
have seen that the DC therapy have been
applied both in solid as well as
methodological tumors so this is also an
important choice and based on this also
the antigen should be chosen
um and a very final point that is
becoming more and more important is um
how do you combine this therapies clear
the probability DC therapy alone is not
enough
um it has been seen that is often
applied after surgery which makes sense
and you can also obtain the antigen from
their biopsy
um but it's been also seen that DC
therapy together with chemotherapy or
radiotherapy can work in Synergy for
several reasons especially the release
of antigen due to the therapy but lately
many Publications have highlighted how
checkpoint blockade and also other type
of immunotherapy could actually
synergize with DC therapy
as we will see also later at the end of
the webinar however any very important
point we want to point out
um for the next part of the webinar is
the choice of the type of genetic cells
so majority of the C therapies so far in
the last 15 years was done with the
monocyte derived dendritic cells however
there are other two ways to obtain DC
with primary bloody C
or with the cd34 derivedc and in the
next part of the webinar we will see how
Blood DC can be actually a good choice
and how can be actually manufactured in
an efficient way
so let's summarize which are the
strategies to design the Next Generation
these vaccines and to make this therapy
efficient and working in patients
so as we mentioned one way is to explore
bloody C subsets
um for the vaccination as we will see in
a few seconds
um we have seen that the role of new
antigen could be the future so in
improving of algorithm for new antigen
prediction and system to synthetize in a
quick way Neurontin is actually a
critical and it would be definitely
something we see in the future
um we also should identify which are the
suitable indication and the right
patient stratification for DC therapy
um in some cases it has been seen also
engineered and dirty cells
um can be the way to improve the
efficacy of vaccination and the potency
of the DC together with the proper
maturation and migration stimulus
the combination with immunotherapy seems
to be really the future especially with
checkpoint inhibitors and all together
the hope is that this different
combination can really help DC therapy
to be successful
but let's focus now specifically on the
option to explore different disease
subsets
so let's have a look at the bloody C
based cancer vaccine
as mentioned there are several ways to
obtain dendritic cells the classical way
explored in the past for the Sea therapy
was to derive them from monocytes
however both in human and mouse it has
been identified
um three different subsets
that are typical or of the DC
compartment the myeloid or conventional
DC and the plasma cyttoid disease
so the myeloid conventional C also
divide in two subsets so often called
cdc1 and cdc2 the CDC one is
characterized in human by the expression
of CD 141 and the cdc2 by the expression
or cd1c and they all have a counterparty
mouse although in Mouse these cells have
a slightly different expression of of
markers
bloody C can be obtained by from cancer
patients in a similar way as described
before so via alliteration of the
peripheral blood into leukoc versus
product and then after the manufacturing
however in this case differently than
the modici the cells are not to
differentiated from other side but they
are simply enriched from the blood
and then later on exactly as for the
more DC it is needed to mature and load
the cells with antigen
the native cells subset might have a
very different phenotypical and
functional roles
um as described before there are a lot
of markers that identify the cells that
you can see here
and some of them can indeed be used to
um isolate the cells from the blood of
in general they have a specific
development and pattern of growth factor
and transcriptional factor in some cases
this transcriptional Factor might also
be used in Mouse models to study the
role of these cells
and they all Express slightly different
patterns of
um of tlrs or surface
surface
receptor that are needed to identify the
pathogens for example in a case of cdc-1
the tlr3 is really prominent in a queso
cdc2 the tlr1 and tlr9 in the cases with
PDC the TR7 until 9.
uh they express slightly different
cytokine
um cytokines so in the case of CDC one
they are main producer producer of the
type 3 interferon the sequencer from
Lambda but also while 12 and type 1
interferonine lower levels whereas the
cdc2 express more pro-inflammatory in
anti-inflammatory cytokines including
the il-12 the PDC instead expressed the
type 1 interference mainly
and they are located also slightly
differently in Vivo in the case of cdc2
and cdc1 they are residents in the
lymphonode and they can found be found
in blood although in lower levels
especially for the CDC one
um and the immigratory subsets are
present in peripheral artificial
lymphonodes in the case of the PDC
um they are resident in lymphoid tissue
and it can be also found in blood but
also for example in lung in the case of
mouse and tonsils
these cells might have overlapping
function of course but they're a bit
like specialized in different activities
for example in a case of CDC one they
are a highly specialized in Cross
presentation so in the activation or the
response cd8 and CD and th1
T cells that is very important against
tumors intracellular pathogens that's
why they are really correlating with a
beneficial prognosis in cancer
they depend really on the conditions so
depending on the sector like cocktail
Emilio they might induce either th1 th2
or th17 polarization in some cases also
cda30 cell response via cross
presentation but in a less in a less
strong weight than the acdc-1 and they
also respond to extracellular pathogens
and allergens that's why they are also
involved in the in these diseases um
mostly more than other subsets and they
also contain the t-reg and th17
homeostasis in londonghat
in the case of PDC instead they are the
first camera the first sales activity
during the inflammatory response they
are really fast and they do this as we
mentioned before with the production of
interferon type one they can stimulate
also by cross-presentation cd8 and they
in some cases correlate to put a poor
prognosis in cancer although this is
still a bit debate and depend on the
situation
um in general however all the subset of
dendritic cells they are not really well
studied yet in the tolerogenic role
they are also able to induce tolerance
in some situation upon certain
stimulation
so we have seen how different dendritic
cell subsets have different phenotypes
and also different functionalities now
it's possible to take advantage of these
different specializations to build up
specific therapies that can be different
for different cancer type or different
conditions here we can see some
preliminary results of the use of blood
and reticence subset in the country
monotherapy
so as mentioned our functionalities and
the possibility to play with
functionalities as definitely an
advantage compared to Modi C and it is
also a hypertized that the different
subset might have also a superior
antigen presenting features compared to
the modicity another advantage of the DC
subset or bloody C compared to modicity
a generation is that is much quicker it
can be done with an enrichment taking
only a few hours and a maximum of 24
hours for the total maturation and
antigen loading and this also implies
that there is less variability in the
process so is more possible it is
possible to control better the
manufacturing compared to the modicity
system
in this slide you can see a very nice
example of how different subset of
dendrity cells can also give different
results depending on the contest on the
left side you see a preclinical
model in Mouse of two different type of
cancer we are depending on the on the
experimental setting and the and the
cancer actually is either the CDC one or
the cdc2 subset that is more successful
in the in the reducing tumor volume and
on the right side is a nice example of a
clinical trials run using plasma
saturated cell vaccination where you can
clearly see an advantage
on the um on a quarter of patients
compared to match controls
so to summarize this first part we can
see that the dendritis cell based
vaccination as for sure some advantages
first of all you can choose one or more
specific DC subset based on the
functionality you can control the
arduant and the antigen co-delivery you
can also have extensive choice of
adduance to play with and also the
antigen diversity is still under
exploration and in general we know the
personalized products might enhance
efficacy however there are still a lot
of disadvantage so in our tolerable Cell
Therapy requires definitely more complex
manufacturing and logistic issue when
it's not off the shelf
and the we know that the migration of
the situ lymphonode is still not optimal
so there's still a lot of
um part to to fix and to fine-tune to
make this therapy really working and
there's also another practical aspect of
that especially for bloody c
um the cells have a very limited number
so indeed we have seen how different
dendritic cell subsets from blood can
have a very low frequency and you can
notice this from this data on the right
side especially for the subset of cdc-1
it can be extremely rare this is one of
the many challenges in working with
bloody C another one is also to
establish a reliable secultural system
to make sure that the diffuse cells that
you get from the enrichment that they
are fully functional and enabled and
viable and able to activate these cells
and finally all these different steps of
manufacturing require the need of a
robust and simple flow cytometry
strategy
that is necessary to QC properly the DC
subset with the one it can be also a
complex gating strategy and also
eventually potency assay to measure how
they activate T cells awesome
so we have seen how many
different points can be a challenge for
a researcher that decide to go into the
richest cell manufacturing however we
can suggest two ways to solve these
problems and to to overcome some of
these issues with our climax Prodigy
platform and you will hear soon from
Marius how you could really optimize
bloody seed and reduce so blood and
retic cell manufacturing with our clean
Max prodigy
thank you very much Christina my name is
Marius and I would like to show you how
The cleanmax Prodigy platform addresses
the challenges for the manufacturer of
cell-based cancer vaccines
generally speaking there are a number of
requirements for sustainable cell
manufacturing it is important to have an
automated and scalable system that
provides High reproducibility
further standardized quality controls
and potency assets as well as
standardized Protocols are essential and
finally the ease of handling
patient-derived samples and cost
efficiency of such systems are very
important factors
these requirements were the starting
point for the development of the
cleaning Max Prodigy it allows among
other functions automated generation of
several cell types such as dendritic
cells in a closed setting the operator
can attach the cell Source such as
leukopheresis and all the reagents
needed for the process
to the hangers on top of the instrument
all the ports are then connected to a
single-use disposable sterile tubing set
the instrument will then move the cells
inside the tubing set during the process
via a peristaltic pump
while a graphic interface guides the
user through the process step by step
the barcode reader allows to register
lot numbers and identification codes of
samples to minimize the risk of
recording errors
once the process starts the target cells
are labeled and enriched via magnetic
separation and moved to the cultivation
chamber for eventual maturation and
antigen loading in case of dendritic
cells sampling pouches allow to easily
collect
the fraction of cells to S at several
steps of the process for Quality
controls
the cleaning Works Prodigy blood disease
system is a two-step process
encompassing the depletion of B cells
and monocytes during the pre-depletion
and the subsequent enrichment with the
option for culture of the three DC
subsets
the pre-depletion allows the preparation
of up to 40 billion white blood cells in
as much as 600 milliliters during a
process time of up to five hours with
only 45 minutes of Hands-On time the 3DC
subsets can equally be enriched from 40
billion cells to a purity of up to 90
percent averaging a yield of 60 percent
for the enrichment and culture process
the estimated Hands-On time is two hours
during a process that can last up to 24
hours if DCs are cultured matured and
loaded with antigens
the system was designed in a way that
the user may choose from four different
preset cases these cases are grouped
into two enrichment in culture cases and
two enrichment only cases in each group
the user may choose from the enrichment
of PDC and cdc2s or the enrichment of
cdc-1 cdc2s and pdcs in case of in case
the DCs are cultured the user needs to
attach suitable medium to the instrument
and then thanks to the flexible protocol
gets to program the time point for the
administration of the stimulation
reagent and the antigen loading
let's look at some of the performance
data obtained with the Blood DC system
using enrichment only cases
pdcs identified by their expression of
cd123 and cd303 were obtained to
purities of up to 30 percent
while CDC wants identified by the
expression of cd1 for one could be
obtained to periods of up to eight
percent and lastly cdc2s identified by
the expression of FC Epsilon receptor 1
and cd1c could be obtained to purities
of up to 35 percent on the top right
panel you can see that across many
different donors these purities were
reproducibly obtained and taken together
all these three subsets in a group that
we now call The Blood DC Group we can
show that across many different donors
we reliably
isolate these blood DCS up to
frequencies between 67 and 70 percent
exhibiting a viability between 90 and
100 percent
so in conclusion starting from 1 billion
white blood cells we can obtain 10
million blood diseases
however the recovery rate across
different donors still varies greatly
now what about the functionality of
these
three DC subsets
in order to induce cytokines secretions
by all three subsets we had to find a
combination of pattern recognition
receptor ligands that would induce the
activation of all three subsets it is
known from the literature that pdc's
mainly expressed Telo 7 and Tila 9 well
in cdc's
the combinations of other tlrs have been
described namely tlr3
is expressed in both cdc1s and cdc2s
thus using the combination of polyic
atila 3 lignin r84a the tlr78 ligand we
should be able to induce the expression
of pro-inflammatory cytokines and
interference
and consequently upon 24 hour in vitro
stimulation of these blood disease
using r848 and polio IC we can detect
the expression of interferon alpha il-6
il-10 il-12 tnf alpha and interferon
Lambda
and in line with these results we could
also detect the upper regulation of the
activation marker cdad on all DC subsets
24 hours after simulation with the
combination of r848 and poly IC
similar results were obtained for the
activation marker cd86 and also the
chemokine receptor ccr7
finally we tested the capacity of our
blood disease to re-simulate antigen
Pacific T cells in vitro in classic
re-stimulation experiments to this end
we loaded our blood disease
with different types of the pp65
immunodominant CMV derived antigen
and co-cultured them with T cells and we
could show that only in the presence of
either the MRNA coding for pp65 or the
peptide
a specific immuno dominant peptide of
the pp65 the whole pp65 protein or the
peptida peptide pool
cd8 positive
tetramer positive T cells expanded
and we could also show further that the
proliferation of these cells was mainly
found amongst Tetra and positive CDI T
cells
and finally in order to assess the
quality and also composition of our
blood disease
we have developed in collaboration with
Yolanda DeVries from the name University
a fox panel that allows us to identify
our blood DC subsets
real quick as an overview we would
exclude the debris
only gate on life cells using the live
dead marker 7 Aid
um further gate on cd45 positive cells
and from there select the side scatter
low cells then we would exclude all cd14
and cd20 positive cells and from there
we check the abundance of pdcs by the
markers that I mentioned before cd123
and cd303 and also the abundance of CDC
ones by the expression of cd1 for one
here from this we have to apply a little
trick and use the non-gate basically
exclude the cd1 for once and then
exclude also the cd123 positive cells in
order to get a pure
population of our FC Epsilon receptor
one expressing in cd1 C1 expressing
cdc2s
all these phenotyping protocols and the
details of these protocols can be found
online and the link provided here
so for the last part of this webinar we
would like to discuss a couple of
examples on how to possibly enhance
dc-based vaccinations by combining it
with other immunotherapies such as
checkpoint inhibitor blockade
and to this end I would like to remind
everybody on the function of checkpoint
inhibitor blockade T cells are
recognized as the main effector cells
fighting tumors and to this end these
tumors have to be infiltrated by T cells
thus the presence is very important
these T cells have to be functional and
these T cells have to recognize the two
Associated antigens
however they are very important and very
well studied inhibitory Pathways that
are also engaged by the tumor in order
to repress the effect of functions of
those T cells and the two most prominent
examples of those inhibitory Pathways is
the cd80 and 86 interaction with ctla4
on the T Cell side and the pdl1 pd1
um interaction between DCS and T cells
so using therapeutic antibodies now
blocking or let's say breaking up these
interactions and therefore blocking
these inhibitory Pathways we're kind of
releasing the brakes that the tumor is
putting on the effective function of
those T cells
now when combining dc-based vaccines
with checkpoint inhibitor blockade
we are basically providing the T cells
with more antigen presentation in the
lymph node and at the same time taking
away the blockade through the ctla4 axis
meaning that we are
expanding higher numbers of activated T
cells and at the same time in the
peripheral tissue so in the effective
phase these T cells
are getting less exhausted because they
receive less signals through their pd1
receptor
and our clinical collaborator in
Brussels Professor Bart nines has
already shown that the combination of
dc-based vaccines and checkpoint
inhibitor blockade is very feasible and
safe in his case he used the CDC tools
together with anti-ctli4 anti-pd1 and
anti-pdl1 in prostate cancer patients
for the future now he's looking into
creating synergies between the DC
subsets namely the CDC ones and cdc2s
together with this checkpoint immunity
checkpoint inhibitor blockades
so taken together we think that by
developing The Blood DC enrichment
culture system
that it's tailored to dress all the
requirements that we mentioned earlier
that are very important for a
sustainable cell Manufacturing
we can now address
questions
um on which DC subset to choose how to
improve the new antigen prediction how
to stratify our patient groups and
cohorts right maybe even engineering or
dendritic cells and then we can also
work on improving their maturation so
that they may migrate in Vivo even
better and finally as just mentioned now
this opens the door also to obtain
reproducible qualities of DC subset
preparations in order to combine these
with other immunotherapies
and so on the basis of this Blood DC
system we can now address all these
questions in order to enhance the
efficacy of DC therapy
please take note of our disclaimer
last but not least
um we would like to thank all the people
that were involved in developing this DC
system there is all the members of the r
d team
including myself and our manager and our
team obviously Christina and her team
from product management clinical
development all our scientific
collaborators
um and thank you very much for your
attention
and we're very happy to take questions
thank you Christina and Marius for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
do both process steps need to be run one
after the other or is a break between
the two steps possible
okay I can take that question
um
these two process steps are designed
to
be running a consecutive
fashion but there's no problem with
storing the
pre-depleted fraction
and
um
maybe starting it overnight at four
degrees and then continuing the process
you know
a way that it's set up for two days
so yeah there is a possibility to to
take a break and uh
let's say prolong or extend this whole
thing over two days
okay thanks
next question
what kind of blood products can be used
for DC isolation
well the process was designed
for leucophoresis products
for of two sides I think for half a
liter or even 600 ml
um but we can also use let's say
mobilize lucophoresis products or even
smaller blocks uh
say drawn
from patients
um
but it's all around the let's say whole
blood and necophysis products
as starting material well
all right thank you next question
answer are the therapies more effective
towards
well that's a
that's a very good question and I mean
if we look at
scientific data we know that dendritic
cells have been proven very
effective in melanomas
um they've been very uh let's say safe
less effective in colorectal Cancers and
in pancreatic cancers
I think the one mesmerizing result from
a lot of research with dendritic cell
basic scenes is that they've been proven
in all cases as very safe
and only mildly effective
so and up to our opinion it is due to
the fact that the cell preparations that
were being used
could not be produced in a very let's
say reproductive reproducible Manner and
under very standard conditions because a
lot of labs around the world that were
doing these studies had their own little
ways to produce these cells and they
couldn't produce a lot of
um standardized batches out of this so
we can say that there is a safety aspect
that has been proven over and over and
there's an Effectiveness that has been
proven in certain cases in very specific
combinations and I think melanoma is
probably the most prominent I know there
are a lot of studies around pancreatic
and colon cancer but here the
effectiveness is of let's say it's a
case-to-case
um effective Effectiveness and really
had to look at specific cases now
Maybe
Maybe
Christina here
yeah I think it's yes exactly as Mario
said they have been tested in many
cancer many melanoma one was one of the
most tested I think there's also to do
on a type of mutation rate
um I think we see vaccine is really
appropriate for those
um cancer that have awesome eye mutation
rate because advantage of identity cells
is that you can
um I mean they're quite flexible and if
example in the case of Neo antigen or
latimalize it you can address many
mutations at the same time
um this is something for example a car
key therapy is not so flexible for
because there is just one car construct
for one antigen and you're a bit stuck
with that and if the cancer mutate then
escapes basically you are in your
response I think this is a point to keep
in mind also when designing the therapy
uh the immunotherapy which type of of
mutation rate for example infiltration
of Celsius in there
vaccine has been tested both for solid
tumor and also for mythological tumor
and depending on the setting he was
working with more or less efficiency but
the factors are many as we said in the
webinar
all right thank you
um next question
could you please compare this type of
vaccine with mRNA vaccine something like
efficacy
Christine do you want to go ahead or
yeah no uh is a very good question
um yeah so
as we said so the MLA vaccine
um technology is a kind of it could be
also kind of complementary to deceive
vaccination in the sense that all this
work done for sequencing the the tumor
and the uh and doing
um yeah new antigen approach could be
done then using uh directly mRNA like
so-called naked RNA or liposomes as the
the copy 19 vaccine or
um or with it a vector that is a cell
like the British cells
um they are a reason to believe that the
the cells so that the dendritic cells
have many more function than this so
they could be more
um more flexible and could be engineered
could you could do a lot of more work to
make them very efficient against the
cancer uh the MRNA vaccine against
cancer is still also in uh experimental
phase there are very good results for
that but is not yet completely uh clear
whether they are more or less efficient
and the richest cells per se
um
so I think we will see so we know of
course Mna vaccine obviously work
against viral diseases because that's
what we see with the coveted vaccines
but it doesn't mean that it will work
perfectly for cancer because as we know
cancer is much more complicated to to
attack than a virus and um so so far
there is not a comparison this is my
personal opinion but I'm also curious to
see how the results from many studies
that biontech is doing on cancer
patients will go maybe Marius you can
add on that yeah I just you know I'd
like to add that I think historically
these Mr and Havoc scenes at least on
the side of biontek they were designed
to uh
uh let's say produce a cancer vaccine
and I think the fact that you alluded to
um that dendritic cells are very
important also in those liposome packed
mRNA vaccines is that actually dendritic
cells or other myeloid cells need to
take up those liposomes and then mediate
the immune response I think
the specific circumstance in the tumor
is that we have a tumor micro
environment that's highly affected by
the tumor type
and an infection context those dendritic
cells that take up you know the MRNA
vaccine upon intramuscular
Administration they can just then you
know wander to the draining lymph node
and after migration to distribution they
can use the immune response it's just
that this is probably not working as
well in cancer at the moment because the
tumor microenvironment is inhibiting you
know the full-blown DC function and I
think that's where the dc-based uh
vaccination or vaccines in our like the
strategy that we just presented comes in
is that we take out those cells from the
context and we induce the activation and
the stimulation and then feed them with
the antigen and put them back into this
context and by taking them out of the
tumor microenvironment this is you know
it's not always just let's say
anti-inflammatory but it's it's doing a
lot of things with the dendritic cells
that
at the end make them
sometimes even
let's say
[Music]
it's not only anti-inflammatory but it's
tolerogenic even you know but taking
them out of this context and then you
know feeding them with the antigen and
the stimulants and everything outside
and bringing them again enhances the
chance to you know really make these
effective antigen presenters even in the
tumor micro environment that's what I'd
like to add
yep
interesting thank you next question
rather than cancer what are the other
diseases this vaccine is tested against
thank you so matters just said that so
the Trinity said can also be tolerogenic
so depending on the cocktail used and
this has been exactly done by uh for
with the monocy derived and dirty cells
um for for example diabetes I think
um
other autoimmune diseases basically so
this has been tested so it says that we
are clinical trials using modc uh for
intelligence setting to counteract some
autoimmune diseases
and HIV so also viral diseases if I
remember correctly but only with
modicity
um with bloody C we didn't see yet
anything and uh we sent in the webinar
also it's not so clear so how to make
them tolerogenic I think maybe you can
comment on these matters
yeah well the
I totally agree though
let's say amazing or the what makes this
a very um
multi-functional system is that
dendritic cells have a lot of facets and
you can either make them you know
stimulatory or induce them with teal
ligands and then also render them
tolerogenic but obviously you really
have to make sure that you
um determine the dendritic cell biology
that comes out of your uh cocktail that
you stimulate the cells with so
it's very important and it's not easy
and we suggest here using the blood
disease which is a subset of three
different DC so they all have
specializations so that's something that
needs to be evaluated firstly but I
think this as a platform really provides
you with a lot of opportunities to go
either way you know tolerogenic or maybe
uh
inflammatory and antigen presenters to
induce an immune response against this
thank you
um
um to isolate DC from cancer patients
does it matter if they are young or old
male or female and do responses of
patients somewhat depend on their age
sex
Etc
well that's a very clinically every
question
yes no I don't think there is any
special difference in male or female I
cannot imagine why but there would be
probably difference in younger older or
dizzy so
um
yeah they left the stage of disease also
the immune
um if the person's meal compromise or
not because of course the the amount of
cells is crucial as person is you know
compromised might have a less cell soon
and the deficiency of the the recovery
will be lower and and things like that
so
um we for sure matters exactly like if
the physiology or the pathology of the
person
um but yeah it's a very clinical
question I can answer as well it's tough
to say I think what I would like to
answer to this question is that in
cancer therapy
be it dendritic cell based or you know
with checkpoint Inhibitors patient
stratification is always very important
and patient certification includes the
sex the age it includes also other
infections maybe comorbidities these
kind of things so this definitely has to
be taken consideration but at this time
point also for me it would be tough to
give that a clear-cut reply reply
okay thank you next question
coup is regular mode of administration
for DC vaccines intra-tumeral
I'm not entirely sure I understood the
first part of the question yeah
who is regular mode so um what is the
regular mode maybe yeah maybe of
administration okay yes
um did you want to say something casino
right away or
no no you could have gone I just I think
it's a good point the route of
administration is very important
um we know
that there are right now I think the
trial that I just mentioned at the end
that's using DC's in combination with
checkpoint Inhibitors is using an
intratrimal
injection of these cells but we also
know from other uh clinical trials that
they have been using even inter-lymph
note uh injections of these cells and
this is all obviously trying it's an
effort in order to avoid the fact that
these cells don't home that well or that
don't migrate that well so I would say
the closer you can get to a spot where
an immune response is elicited or the
tumor itself would be preferential
thank you
next question
it's a very technical question and I
think uh is a very easy answer to this
one those are single use
um compounds that are delivered with the
system and they are strongly recommended
to be only used once
question and AG loading
well that's also a very technical
question we
at the moment
the sell your product is transferred
into a single back and then this bag can
be uh let's say
welded off the system and used
for a liquidation but this has to be
done in a sterile environment by the
produce of the cells themselves
hey well it looks like we have time for
one more question is the blood-brain
barrier an obstacle for use of DC
vaccines with CNS tumors
so actually
um is a very also medical question
um
I know for sure modisi have been used
many times for glioblastoma
um treatment so for brain diseases or
brain brain cancer so I somehow assume
actually is a good question and I didn't
think about it but I assume that yeah
the idea is that they they work uh and
they can pass the blood-brain barrier on
the other hand okay I'm not that strong
on how the immune system works in the
brain because because there's a
limitation of the it's not so the same
as in other other organs but at the end
of the day what you want to have is the
energy cells in the lympho node and the
T Cell infiltrating so actually the
question will be more like if T Cell
Prime by DC vaccine are able to enter
the barrier I think this will be the the
important step and I don't remember 100
but I think the in injection of this DC
in the glioblastoma trials they were
done probably
or some in some other ways or maybe with
systemic uh like in the blood cannot
remember but but definitely you know the
person that asked this question I
suggest just like to to check out this
uh few
um
um some some trials that have been done
in global stomach with monocyte rather
than dirty cells and then you can assume
that Bloody C would be similar
I agree
all right well thank you Christina and
Marius do you have any final comments
for our audience
yeah so from my side
um I think it's an exciting time to see
all this immunotherapy coming together
with many different approaches no not
just synthetic cells but many other type
of cells or as we said you know with
mRNA technology with the new antigen
sequencing with the check upon inhibitor
combination and so on so what we wanted
to give you here was just an overview of
how so they did they say the big picture
and then how all these different
approaches might even work complementary
together
um and our system so our our platforms
climax Prodigy and the Bloody system is
actually a tool that you can
um use to say play around uh in this
field with experimental medicine we
don't have all the answers we don't know
yet how the different subsets really
work together
um in which cancer will work better on
less this is something that we can use
an as an exemption but uh assumption but
um it's up to you so up to the
researchers to use our our support to
actually make these discoveries and we
hope that we can support you with that
at the best
all right well thank you again Christina
and Marias for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor milteni
biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye